hey I'm Kurt Davina and this is remember
when the show about old stories in
gaming history told with a new
perspective and today we're looking back
at a catastrophic watch that was a ps3
that in Shirin
led to the ps4 is success back in 2006
the world was eager to see with Sony
head up its sleeves for the ps3 and
respectfully so the ps2 was the most
successful video game console ever made
putting Sony at the top of the food
chain all eyes were on its successor and
sure the Xbox 360 had already been out
for a year prior but as mr. PlayStation
boss cos price said himself we have said
on many occasions that the next
generation doesn't start until we say it
does and well I don't think it panned
out that way so let's start where most
of these stories begin III fourteen
years ago so the 2006 review of the
PlayStation 3 is kind of notoriously
known for being really dry and in
comparison Xbox 360 which was shown and
TV with Elijah Wood well I can see where
people are coming from but on paper
there was some pretty compelling stuff
that was announced that day so we're
gonna split this into two categories but
good and the bad so first up those
completely backwards compatible with ps1
ps2 and DVD formats second featured this
ambitious new powerful cell technology
that was supposedly more powerful than
the 360 employ Sony just could not stop
talking about it
husband's week it's good but under good
it was also blu-ray compatible which at
the time was exciting in new technology
so that made the entire system just a
big push in to HD the presentation was
even the reveal of Assassin's Creed
Uncharted and Metal Gear Solid 4 so I
had games all this is really promising I
mean even if it had a few hiccups
so here's this giant enemy crab see if
he shows up oh here comes and yeah the
absence of Rumble four six axis
technology was kind of a hard pill to
swallow but at the time motion control
was an exciting interesting thing in
theory on paper this looks good
that was until they revealed the price
the 65 Playstation 3 for five hundred
and ninety-nine US dollars six hundred
and fifty nine dollars Canadian and in
that moment all these things all the
sweet good stuff suddenly just felt a
little less enticing and it happened
with the reveal of the price which and
of itself felt very not Sony like to get
perspective on all this I turn to Jeff
Bakalar
tech games a writer dude for cement the
thing I remember first off and I think a
lot of people remember was that insane
sort of price tag I couldn't understand
how they were justifying it and I also
remember being super confused as to how
they were going to roll out their
backwards-compatibility ambitions it
seemed a shaky with this like hardware
promise remember all the weirdness with
the controller and like the sixaxis and
like some of them didn't have Rumble at
the beginning and I always remember that
that being like how could they not have
Rumble they basically took it out from
where they ended with ps2 they were
promising like two HDMI ports and there
was like this thing will have eight
controller compatibility and I just
remember being like I don't know why I
need all this stuff but thank you I
couldn't understand what they were
trying to do with this thing if that
came out in 2020 I feel like people
would be like well this you've done too
much historically speaking Sony has
always priced its consoles with a
competitive edge the ps1 when it came
out was $2.99 which was $100 cheaper
than its main competitor the Sega Saturn
and then when the ps2 came out it was
priced at 299 making it not only a cool
new console but also one of the most for
DVD players on the market so when the
PlayStation 3 was announced with this
599 dollar price tag it just felt a
little confusing and when the 360 had
already been out for a year prior and
significantly cheaper at 399 it made
even less sense so how did this happen
why did this happen
leading into that ps3 launch they seem
to be this unstoppable force you know
they were so well cemented positionally
you know obviously you had the original
Xbox come out during the the lifespan of
ps2 it sort of felt when all of a sudden
done kind of like a drop in in the
bucket compared to what ps2 was was
reliably able to do and I just remember
thinking like oh you know how can anyone
or anything kind of stop the momentum
that you know Sony seemed to have at the
time and this incredibly faithful you
know installation of people who were
just kind of PlayStation people and it
that just seemed unstoppable I think a
lot of it too was maybe this sort of
hubris where you could you could be Sony
and you could charge this we've chosen
this strategy and we've chosen to
include these type of Hardware choices
and that's why this thing is so much
money and if you want the latest and
greatest state-of-the-art home console
that's what it's gonna cost and I feel
like that was sort of the reasoning that
kind of kept backing into this hey the
hardware is so advanced it costs this
much and I and I just remember as a
consumer being like well that's just not
good enough for me right now Sony may
have thought that they could sell the
consumer anything at the time which is
understandable to a degree not only did
it have two of the most successful
consoles ever made but the PlayStation 2
was pretty much responsible for wiping
Sega out of the hardware business and it
sold three times more than the Xbox and
GameCube combined that price review was
the byproduct of full-blown hubris which
is a fancy word for excessive pride and
self-confidence I know stuff Sonia was
convinced it had taken hold of the
entire gaming market and without a doubt
sell its consumers on a billion
investment cell technology in simplest
terms cell technology was a
microprocessor
made to power an array of electronic
devices cell phones computers TVs and of
course video game consoles however that
was the thing it was designed for
multiple products all with different
uses and not from the ground up for
gaming very quickly the ps3 started to
feel more like a Trojan horse pushing
Sony's big investment rather than a
piece of hardware designed first and
foremost for gaming and with new tech
and innovation the price was driven up
which makes cosmo rise opening statement
at e3 all the more telling we must take
risks to reap the rewards and we're not
about cutting corners to rush a product
to market and we're certainly not
interested in gimmicks clever rhetoric
or conventional thinking and it wasn't
only the consumer that turned its back
on ps3 and flock to the 360 but also
game developers as it turns out Sony's
fancy new cell technology was not easy
to develop on in fact Gabe Newell the
valve dude himself said in 2007 the ps3
is a total disaster on so many levels I
think it's really clear that Sony lost
track of what consumers and what
developers wanted he also said quote
they should just cancel it and do a
do-over more like cell technology was a
hard sell when it came to developing on
the Xbox 360 it was similar to a PC
which was the industry standard it's
what developers built their careers on
understanding cell technology however
was completely new which in turn forced
depths that take time and research to
learn it understand it and harness it
which caused huge setbacks for
developers that were working on
multi-platform projects think of it this
way English is your first language and
now suddenly you're in a foreign country
and you have to relearn how to
communicate lo siento no hablo espanol
it was an expensive hurdle for dev
support their games to the ps3 even
though it was a more powerful system
it's full potential is difficult
then to which in turn made most
third-party games perform noticeably
worse on the ps3 versus the xbox360 and
if you played Skyrim on the ps3 you know
what I'm talking about but there was a
turning point so all things considered
the ps3 had a rough launch first there
was a shortage of blue lasers which were
required for blu-ray discs and because
of this the launch was delayed several
months in Europe so that was a setback
and on top of it being extremely
expensive the exclusives were slim with
the exception of resistance and Genji
days of played the giant crab game
attack its weak point for massive damage
doing parts of these things and a lot of
miscommunication and branding issues the
ps3 struggled for years but there was a
turning point specifically in 2009 with
the release and rebranding of the slim
model first
it literally slimmed the thing down
which to me personally made it a whole
lot more attractive it also ran better
and was quieter second it got rid of
unused features like sixaxis and funny
enough reintroduced Rumble all of which
knocked the price down to that magical
PlayStation number of $2.99 but there
was still one last thing to truly fix
its course the thing that would really
show what made this console so great the
Uncharted trilogy LittleBigPlanet God of
War 3 Metal Gear Solid 4 heavy ray
infamous Ratchet and Clank The Last of
Us the resistance trilogy Killzone 2 and
3 demon souls Heavenly Sword even games
like journey found their home as ps3
exclusive titles there was a lot of
these games that began to shift the ps3
his reputation from being this big
expensive console that was notoriously
difficult to develop on to being the
home of some of the most critically
acclaimed games of the generation
I didn't buy my ps3 until 2010 because
of the slim model because of that price
point and these exclusive titles and
sure say what you will about games like
heavy rain but at the time experiences
like that just simply didn't
anywhere else and Naughty Dog it feels
needless to say but between uncharted in
the Last of Us they offered the closest
feeling of what it was like to actually
be playing a movie now that isn't to say
that I was an envious of Xbox players
who had gears and week and sneak king
but there was a distinctiveness of
quality and polish that PlayStation 3
exclusive had that just felt unrivaled
and consumers started to take notice in
sales started going up oh and remember
the whole thing with gabe newell about
not wanting to develop in the ps3 well
in 2010 at e3 he took the stage to
publicly say that it was more
developer-friendly
and then portal 2 came out on the ps3
with a deal that if he bought it for the
system you also got for free on Steam so
well then gave it by the end that the
planes shifted and ps3 went toe to toe
with the Xbox 360 with one of the most
impressive comebacks in gaming history
and eventually managed to outsell the
360 by a few million units now in 2020
at the tail end of the ps4's lifespan
it's been an entirely different story
and it's 2013 reveal the ps4 didn't seem
to have an agenda there was no talk of
some new tech they invested heavily in
two and a Sony went back to its original
pricing model undercutting the Xbox one
by $100 just as they did with the Sega
Saturn the ps4 was fairly priced geared
towards gamers design with developers in
mind and retained a prominent focus on
first party studios by Megatron as a
result of that the ps4 has sold
exceptionally well but it's hard to see
if that would have been the case were
not for Sony flying too close to the Sun
with the ps3 but science Microsoft and
Sony lost that console war anyways to
the Nintendo Wii and unlike Sony
Nintendo capitalized on that success
welcome to the world of Wii U well we'll
save that story for the next episode
yeah hey thanks for watching this
episode remember went now the last one
was about the Xbox and you'll find a
link to that and other episodes that
remember when in the description below
now to finish off this holy trilogy
we're gonna be doing this big hunka
Nintendo Beauty next so be on the
lookout for that we really love this
show remember when so please if you love
it - make sure to let us know share it
if you will if your heart does so desire
you can also follow me on Twitter if
you'd like a curt underscore in Davina
alright thanks for being here be well
stay safe until next time see ya